all right we
are now live for another political
theory and
practice discussion and i
delayed it this month to this
date because i wanted to get past the
inauguration um i i knew that there were
going to be some you know contestation
going on i you know i was kind of
surprised actually at the
sort that we we ended up having
and um so i i you know i
wanted to see how things settled out
before talking about anything
and determining the topic that we would
discuss this month
and so i settled on um
you know this this discussion uh
primarily centered around unity and
accountability
but also conflict and we could call it
pluralism or
you know how to carry out politics
in in the broad sense not just in the
sense of like getting people elected or
maneuvering power but politics in in
a really much more meaningful sense that
i'll talk about in just a bit
so since the election what we've seen
uh is a number of attempts to
say that the election was illegitimate
in this way or this way or this way
many of which are completely
self-serving because a lot of the
republicans who've been
raising these issues didn't uh question
whether their own
elections were legitimate or
illegitimate
just the presidential one and perhaps
some of
their their opponents who who made it
through
um and so there's there's a lot of stuff
going on there and we saw
you know in in this month uh essentially
an attempt and we're not
even sure exactly how far it goes
there's more and more
coming out about the picture of just how
pervasive some of this stuff was there
was an attempt at
an insurrection or a coup um there's a
lot of
problems with the way in which we're
we're doing politics at this point in
time
um the the f word fascist has been
thrown around quite a lot and i think at
this point in time we
it is actually deserved of a number of
uh different agents people movements
forces within
our society so we're in kind of a mess
and what i want to do
in this session is talk about some of
these
issues of the day and what's going on
with them i'm also going to address you
know and answer
questions and comments and i i want to
frame it in terms of
some ideas or
let's call them conceptions from
classical
political theory and also you know
running into you know the 20th century
with people like say hannah arendt
or jurgen habermas that can be that can
be quite helpful
so i want to remind everybody you know
let's
be civil as as best as we can with each
other
um this is not a talking head
you know msnbc or fox news
uh sort of like throw out bullet points
kind of framework that we're doing here
we're looking to talk thoughtfully about
what's what's actually going on in terms
of politics and for those of you who who
are
you know foreign viewers non-americans
uh not not from the you know united
states of america i don't want to offend
other people from the americas as well
because you know america
is more than just the usa in many
respects
um some of this may seem particularly
you know u.s centric and
that's that's just going to be the way
that it is because that's really what's
what's on
my mind uh living here in a swing state
uh where some of the election stuff
actually did get challenged and then the
challenges were thrown out
and where we have a sitting senator who
is part of
the you know sort of essentially broad
conspiracy to
to do this stuff um who hopefully will
get get recalled or thrown out pretty
soon
uh since he's such an embarrassment to
our state so
it is going to turn this i think some of
the implications are
you know could be applicable to other
uh countries in the present as well
and let's so let's start at the the
beginning right
we had an election and it was a very
hotly contested election it was carried
out under
um extraordinary circumstances due to
the pandemic that we're still
in the middle of which has become
incredibly politicized
it probably shouldn't have become so
but due to the incompetence and and
corruption of the the trump
administration
it was from the very beginning and uh
trump himself did a lot of damage
as a as a figure who held things back
or interfered in the wrong ways and then
people in his administration did as well
and then we can look across you know our
federalized country where local control
is very important and see how
some places handled the pandemic
response while others
didn't and you know wisconsin as a prime
example
we still have republicans right now
trying to knock down a mask
mandate you know so um there's
the covet itself became a hot button
political issue
it drove a lot of things with the
election there were a lot of debates
about you know could you mail in ballots
or
things like that a good bit of
misinformation out there
we've always had the usual attempts at
voter suppression on the part of the
republicans
there's sometimes some voter suppression
on the part of the democrats as well but
primarily it's the republicans
trying to keep people that they think
they don't want voting
from being able to vote we're kind of an
unusual country
in the way that we do elections both in
that we have so many
local laws that make it difficult for
people to vote
and we also allow these election
campaigns to go
on and on forever and for tons and tons
of
money much of which is coming from
corporations
or from you know political action
committees or things like that
uh to be funneled into to our politics
so
we we had a messed up election right
what was unusual about this although
not totally unusual but it reached a
much higher
level of screwed upeness politically
speaking
is the contestation of the election
so right now there's a lot of people
trying to play
equivalency games and say you know
democrats were saying not my president
after trump got elected and um they
you know they were wearing um the
women's march and you know saying you
know saying all sorts of mean things
about trump and blah blah blah blah
right
it wasn't at the you know that that
wasn't to the degree
that what happened after this election
um reached we can say similar things
about bush versus gore right
i remember when that election took place
and i
um i remember actually sitting in
in a cafe in in carbondale which was
pretty liberal
at the time and having a waitress come
up and see me seeing me reading the
economist
you know and talking about the the
election then she like blurted in there
you know he's not my president and i was
like
this i didn't ask you right why don't
you get me my stuff
that you know uh and so this the
sentiment has been around for a long
time
republicans did that with clinton uh
they also did that
hamas with obama you know that's when we
started to see the republican party
really metastasizing
with the tea party and we'll talk about
that that movement in just a bit
but the refusal to concede
and the bringing tons and tons of
frivolous lawsuits
that they knew were frivolous as they
were doing
and the calling for an insurrection
which was not new to trump remember the
liberate uh
michigan thing that led to the michigan
governor
uh not only uh you know people going
into the state house fully armed
they should have been cracked down on
immediately particularly given the long
history of
militia movements in michigan but of
course they weren't because we had you
know people
who were receptive to that in power but
then an actual plot to kidnap her
spurred in in part because of uh what
what trump was promoting
so you know this is
fortunately it was it was a failed coup
but there was
there was arguably a coup that took
place here and so
this sort of sour grapes we're not going
to work with you unless you do
everything
our way attitude is very problematic
no one could say um well the democrats
have done that sort of stuff
look at them you know under
reconstruction time in the south and
yeah
that's a different party actually i mean
the people who are in the democrat party
at that time are now
like staunch uh republican types
so um this is you know this is a
significant
issue that we're facing and politics
so okay we've got that going on politics
is always messy
you don't have real politics with
everybody being on the same page
there has to be some you know different
interests being represented
and having to work things out with each
other and it's usually not to
everybody's
uh benefits and not everybody's happy
with it and they can grouse about it and
[ __ ] about it and say that the other
side are bad people but in general
if you want to have a functioning
political system there have to be some
basic norms that are being
observed and honored and one of those is
you don't rise up against the government
itself
unless you've got some pretty damn good
reasons to do so
and there weren't any in this case the
stop the steel stuff is all [ __ ]
you know and it's been revealed as such
and
it's it's difficult as as like an
independent observer
who is you know a virtue ethicist and
devoted to you know the life of reason
and is also very realistic about
politics
to take those people seriously but we
have to because there's so many of them
now
right and so here's where we get to the
unity thing so
now that we've made it past um
you know we made it past all these
challenges and the inauguration and
attempted coup and all that and trump
has flown away
although there's there's still more
stuff going on in the background with
trump and the possibility of the
republican party itself
having an internal chaos and split which
we'll we'll
hopefully talk about a little bit later
um
you know we there's this call for having
unity
and a call to like understand the other
side who lost
and you know in general i would be quite
receptive to those sorts of things
because
that is what you know classical
political philosophy would generally
counsel if you were dealing with people
who were not
as corrupt as power hungry as
deliberately oppositional as the
republican party
has shown itself to be and their base
has shown itself to be
and if you didn't have you know i'm just
going to say you know
whack job movements like
q anon or the gun nuttery stuff going on
that always appeals to a second
amendment and never has a well-regulated
militia just
just a bunch of losers who you know want
to
spend their money on guns depriving
their family of of you know
money that could be used for for other
things and then go around
you know fully armed intimidating people
and we could you know
anti-covet stuff all these
sorts of things that became mainstream
truth
truthism you know uh you know that that
became a big thing with
with obama and trump was at the center
of that he appealed to that
the tea party was in large part about
that sort of stuff and i got to see the
tea party
emerge i was actually in north carolina
at the time and we were having some very
interesting discussions
in our you know departments about what
what this new phenomenon
actually was you know so
um can you actually work with
people like that can you have unity with
people
who are clearly devoted
to doing whatever they can to make sure
they remain in power or
can obstruct whatever is going on
wisconsin is a prime example
you know we we are the one of the most
gerrymandered
states in the united states we have all
sorts of people who
would not be able to have a seat in
congress
uh if if districts were drawn properly
um but you know that that's that's
something that's been
going on and so we have a state where
republicans dominate
even though they are a minority in the
state
and they'll do anything they can voter
suppression
continuing gerrymandering bringing all
sorts of lawsuits in order to hold on to
power
can you deal with somebody who doesn't
deal in good faith
then the answer is no so these calls for
unity which are coming not just from
people on the right
but also from people in the center and
from some people on the left
i think they're misguided i think at
this point in time and i'm going to put
forth a strong thesis here as somebody
who is not committed to either party but
but right now sees the republican party
as
you know particularly bad i think that
unless the republicans want to do a
little bit more than just
maya culpa oh it was bad and they want
to like put their money where their
mouth is
and take hard stands and say you know
this this aspect was was wrong and we
need to change this
you know the things that we've done to
appeal to our base
and to further radicalize our base in
terms of
you know race or uh
culture war stuff or tendentious
you know use of biblical stuff that's
totally anti-christian
totally against any real interpretation
of christianity that focuses on the
sermon on the mount or cares about that
jesus god and what
what he stood for unless they're
actually going to come clean and say
holy crap did we screw up
i don't know how we let things get to
this fever swamp
that the tea party and the trumpist
movement turned into but
we got to change this and there are
there are republicans like that right
um some of them left the party like the
mayor of waukesha
uh if you don't know what waukesha is
look it up on the map
waukesha county is essentially the
republican capital of the
state of wisconsin and um
you know it's a hotbed for all the
conservative stuff the mayor who was a
republican said you guys are so
nuts i can't deal with you anymore and
you know we have another
personality here in wisconsin charlie
sykes who
has a long bad past of being like a
hardcore racist and
and you know um race baiting in the
milwaukee area but but you know
he became a never trumper and stuck with
it and he's
he's evolved not far enough but but he's
evolved since then
unless the republicans are going to do
that sort of thing
um i don't think that they deserve a
seat at the table
or if they do get a seat at the table
they have to be understood as
only serving themselves only serving the
people that they represent
or corporations or pacs or koch brothers
and they don't deserve to be treated as
you know colleagues or anything like
that
the democrats in my view need to really
play hardball
all this talk about oh we're one nation
we can all come together
that's actually marginalizing the people
who've been so
screwed over and not just by the trump
administration
also by the obama administration also by
the bush administration also by the
clinton administration we go a long ways
back right
all the way back to uh you know my
childhood and the reagan administration
unless we're going to actually like
acknowledge the people who've been
victimized and marginalized and who've
had their votes taken away
i don't want to hear about how some uh
you know trump person feels bad about
something
screw them yeah they were the party of
screw your feelings right
uh feelings you know we have facts facts
trump feelings well they don't get to
have it both ways
and so you know is this what the biden
administration is actually going to do
probably not the biden administration is
going to be pretty center left
most of the people who want to see
things that are associated with the left
but are actually just good common sense
like virtue ethics
classical politics make things for the
common good like
say universal health care or
you know a much fairer economic
landscape that doesn't allow all these
predatory things to be done to
ordinary people and reigns in the
corporations
that's not going to have much of a role
i think in the biden administration
unless we we really push for it
and that's part of what i intend to do
and we have to be very realistic about
the fact that not
not a lot of this is is going to come
through but it's still better than
having
an arguably actually essentially fascist
regime
in in power it's not great but it's
it's certainly better now classical
political theory
would say that you cannot have
um you cannot have fair dealings
between those who won't act at least in
some good faith and now
what's important about that it means
that
it's not just about looking at the other
person across the table
or their constituents and saying you
matter to you're also a person i'm going
to treat you according to certain norms
it does have to do with unity you say
the unity of our political community
and its common good trumps my
programs trumps my constituents
not entirely but i do have to at least
acknowledge that and take that into
account
and that is part of what has been lost
on the republican side
and lost now for i would say about 10
years
it the tea party clearly lost it
the tea party came out of a politics of
resentment
and culture war stuff that was going on
and
effectively took over the republican
party the trump movement just
metastasized that further things like q
anon
um have have you know made it worse in
in other ways as well and they've
brought a whole group of people who
think that
they are the ones who are victimized
they're the ones who are
um you know uh
they are the ones who who are threatened
and all that
and how do you deal with people like
that well that's that's a big
uh that's a big issue a big problem
now people like aristotle
or augustine or hana
rent would say that there is nothing
that says that
any given political community has to be
able to remain in existence and this is
where our american exceptionalism
so often gets us into trouble so
american exceptionalism
is this view that somehow like we're
different than the norm
you know and you know we've got the
thing to to get us through
and it's not it's not the case we're no
different than any other
polity in the world other than you know
the particularities of our history and
ideologies
and and the fact that we happen to you
know be the number one economy for the
present
which is not going to last for you know
for our lifetimes and
and the fact that we've got military
force you know all over the world
which we pay an awful high premium for
if we don't get it together if we
don't figure out how to
effectively deal with the fact that a
significant part of the
population was cool with an attack
on the electoral process
and the capital and we don't find some
ways to
either you know marginalize them
and keep them out of of the political
process there's many of them who are
in the republican leadership right now
um
maybe we need something like a cordon
sanitaire like the the
they had to you know to make sure that
fascist parties couldn't get into power
but we need to do it with individuals
uh and and they're declared things um
we may not ser we may not continue on as
a political community
you know and we are facing
a lot of challenges and we are facing
some significant
rivals both political and economic um
so you know are the democrats a model
at this point in time for like getting
it right i wouldn't say yes
um but they're all that we have to work
with
because we have this stupid two-party
system and one other party is
is clearly so screwed up and corrupt and
power hungry and and you know has a base
that and leadership that believes in all
sorts of
frankly crazy and uh cruel stuff
so it's going to take a lot of
people coming together and it's going to
be an iterative process
and i'm kind of hopeful about
engaging in it but it can also be uh
draining
and uh for some people it's probably
going to be dangerous
as well let's scroll up and take a look
at some of these
comments um so
so good or grown says doesn't it feel
like the fascism versus neoliberalism
showdown
was show put on by the corporations or
was there a real showdown
i you know i i think that's not the way
to look at it um
if you do look at it that way then you
can be a cynic and
say oh it's all just for show man you
know nothing going on
and there may be some aspect of that but
i don't think that's the explanation for
things
haseeb says please make a playlist on
political science well when i get to a
certain level of patreon support i've
pledged to do that
um but that takes time
and and that takes money right
um wavy says i always enjoy these types
of streams
well good um mr big weakness is there
any historical
precedent to the distortion of trump's
true character among his supporters oh
that's an interesting question
people thinking a 70 year old scammer
born into wealth is some made tough guy
yeah i mean there's all sorts of
precedence of people who have been
you know clearly in the reality of who
they are
very different than the public image
that they pre they attempt to project
and that other people circulate around
about them
um and this is a significant thing with
the trump thing and that
that's actually a great point you look
at these people
who make memes that have trump with a
um it doesn't even have to be like a
you know really buff body just a decent
body the guy is a shambles because he
eats crap
all the time and he doesn't exercise and
he's got by the way crazy beliefs about
exercise um that that should have you
know
come to light and people should have
been like this guy's a nutter you know
um and they they think that that's he's
a representation of masculinity
if you know i'll just say this if you
think that trump is a
a guy's guy you're you're
there's something wrong with you you
know and
you know i've heard it said that trump
is sort of like the stupid person's view
of what an intelligent person is like
he is stupid i mean he's stupid on a
number of different
ways right he can't concentrate enough
to read memos
um he says he says stupid things like
maybe
we inject bleach or something like that
just off the
cuff he has very little sense and he's
been extraordinarily lucky to get away
with as much [ __ ] as he
as he has and i think it's because
people have enabled them over and over
and over
again so this is actually a great
question i mean anybody
who who like you know
gets into those memes or you know ben
garrison cartoons or things like that
now on the one hand they're probably not
watching this and if you're dealing with
people like that they're probably at
this point
not directly reachable but you can see
that there there's a
kind of nuttery or insanity going on
all right um bark lord says
uh i have an uncle who served in the
navy for 35 years
he believes people shouldn't vote unless
they have property well
he's got an interesting point of view
that we left behind at least in this
nation
uh more than a century ago so he's kind
of a you know
throwback in that sense i guess i don't
see why it's relevant that he served in
the navy for
35 years plenty of vets are you know
well put together
intelligent people um
who can have sensible political
discussions it must be interesting
talking with him about stuff like that
now i will say
a lot of my family you know because i
you know i come from the midwest
um and many of my family uh live in the
suburbs or in the countryside
quite a few of them are really into
their guns um
a number of them are trump supporters
some of them are q anon believers
you know it is it is uh kind of
difficult when you have to
try to deal with these people
fortunately covet has meant that
you know we don't have to go to family
things anymore
um all right uh wavy says
what do you think about the satirical
remarks made against different schools
of philosophy and voltaire's candide
uh you know they're they're fun uh but
that's about it
um all right um
sn project wouldn't it be more clear in
this discussion not to refer
to the two parties in the us as
republican or democrat but conservative
or liberal
no
the republican party is not remotely
conservative in any real sense of the
term
used to be the conservatives were
pro gun control now the nra
even bankrupt runs the show
that's not conservative that's just
nutty right
uh it used to be that conservatives
actually wanted to protect the
environment
um so-called conservatives in the
present wanted
you know monetize it as much as possible
and then you know let everybody else
live in the crap
uh so no that's that's that's silly um
the parties are called what they're
called i mean you can try to
propose that people you know adopt the
vocabulary that you want people do this
all the time in philosophy by the way
um let's see if you can actually get
that to work
and you know liberal uh the the
democratic party
is not all that liberal um and it all
depends on what you mean by liberal too
there's people who are like oh i'm a
classical liberal you know a lot of
those are republicans
um or they're libertarians who end up
you know effectively voting republican
anyway
so no i i think it's kind of a
non-starter
um barklord my american patriot family
explicitly reject democratic process
yeah and
it's interesting that you say that
because if they really were patriots in
america then they would be for the
democratic process
and um insofar as they're not they're
they're more you know you could call
them fascists or maybe they're like
integral
nationalists or they're just for a
military junta or
something like that or or they're just
you know for oligarchs running things
um but they're not they're not uh
patriots because
this nation very explicitly
uh was about
consensus democratic process all those
sorts of things that's part of our
experiment that's why
alexis de tocqueville wrote democracy in
america and he didn't
he didn't call it oligarchy in america
or something like that
so that's that's a a good thing to to to
think about
um all right
another view all the reading needs to be
put to test of the forced narrative
i don't really know what that means um
let's scroll down a little bit more
barklord neoliberals are in favor of
government facilitating capitalist
interests
neoconservatives also favor conservative
social policies
you know these categories of neoliberal
uh neoconservatives a little got a
little bit more
let's say definite contours to it
neoliberal
is is like the word fascist right
there's there's there's ways in which it
comes out of particular
theories and if if you're going to use
it in that way you got to be kind of
careful about how you apply it or else
everything turns into neoliberalism
and then there's the just use of it as a
slur you know
um like you know when trump first got
elected i was like you know you people
are calling him a fascist we got to wait
and see
um there are certainly some things that
look fascist
you know there's tendencies he's he's
clearly got a base of people who
are fascists um you know
usually all of them are you know white
ethno state people
um but you know
he's got to meet certain criteria and
then when the criteria were met i was
like
there he is he's a fascist and i think
we have to be very careful about the use
of neoliberal
you use it enough and it doesn't mean
anything after a while
you know it's sort of like a
conversation that i had today
on twitter where somebody was
um using the panopticon concept and i
was like
that doesn't really apply here and
there's better concepts that fit
this particular thing that we're talking
about and he's like well but it has some
traits in common and i was like okay
everything has traits in common with
everything
else you want to be very
clear in the concepts that you're using
because otherwise everything just turns
into one unanalyzable
blob right so
all right um
let's see what else we've got there's a
lot of side conversation here
um dennisy paul don't forget about whack
job movements that ate up the whole
russia collusion
hoax yeah i mean sure there's there's
you can find crazy stuff like that on
the left they aren't actually
getting guns and trying to you know
break in and hang people
and kill people and um
so if you want to do some what about ism
with that
or some don't forget about you always
have to do it in proportion
um the russia collusion thing
was um you know
it was sort of a waste of time that's
granted
um clearly russia did interfere in our
election
just not in exactly the same way as the
the collusion people
were saying um
and uh i think that there's other stuff
that that's probably more important to
worry about
right now than that right
uh bark lord the way i understand the
washington consensus is that there's no
alternative to market ideologies the
so-called neutral ideology
you know i don't know that anybody
thinks the markets are
neutral um they usually when they're
talking about it they usually i think
have in the back of their mind that
their favored corporations or donors or
who you know whatever they have stock is
going to do quite well
um and yeah they're it's better to say
that it's sort of
it's not that it's neutral it's that
it's it is the dominant ideology
and it has become so in part because of
centrist third wave democrats
um the market you know
this like let's always have market
solutions is a stupid approach to things
they're
you know anybody who's like the market
is always the best thing
is is just you know they they're
they're lazy they haven't actually
looked at the history of how these
things work
and they don't differentiate there are
some things that might benefit from
privatization there are some things
where it might be good to go to
contractors right
there's other things where it's a
terrible idea
and we need to be able to differentiate
instead of like being pro market
anti-market pro market anti-market
that's
that's not particularly helpful
but you are right that most of the
people in congress
on the republican and democrat side are
typically going to be
you know pro markets whatever that
happens to mean for
for them and it's in part because of of
how much
corporations are able to intervene in
our political process
you know that that's a that's a
significant uh part of it
so all right
um let's see what else we have ross
whitlock
the gop is dead to me so that's an
interesting thing you know i
voted republican in the past i've
actually been a registered republican
when i lived in new york because i i
wanted to be able to
like you know vote in primaries and they
don't have open primaries like like
you know smart states do like wisconsin
does
um which is much more democratic and and
i didn't want to vote in elections where
basically the fix was already in
um i wanted to be able to vote for
something that that mattered
and you know in the past i've i've been
uh supportive of the republican party
against the democrat party but
the current iteration of the dem of the
republican party
is at this point in such a mess like i
was saying earlier
that unless they you know
they could have a come to jesus moment
and
really start sorting things out there's
the danger right now trump is actually
talking about you know going off and
forming a third party that actually
would be a good thing
i think for the republican party it
would not be a good thing
short term but it would allow them to
get rid of
a lot of the um the
problematic elements of their their
party
they would lose elections for a while
but they would be a better party for it
and they would come out of it and they
could start re-articulating
the values that they want without um
being as beholden to to noxious
interests as as they have been i don't
really think that's going to happen
unfortunately i think the republican
party is going to continue on through
demographically you look at the
the you know exit polls and stuff like
that
the republican party even with
gerrymandering
even with voter suppression even with
all these other things that they
routinely do which are against the
common good and against
you know uh any sort of you know notion
of of democracy
uh and it is essentially as
anti-american
they're they're not gonna they're not
gonna have a viable base
in another 20 30 years so they really
have to
not to put a fine point on it either get
their [ __ ] together
or relegate themselves to being a
lunatic fringe
and get used to democratic domination
sort of like during the new deal
period you know if a party doesn't
really
have something to offer except to
the people who are funneling money into
it or getting an emotional charge out of
it
or tying their identity into it it's not
going to be
a viable party in a healthy democracy
for very long and so you know that's
that's a
serious issue all right
uh zeno destroying the statuses
oh statues probably is a pure shame
they'll go for the history textbooks
next
a lot of the history textbooks are [ __ ]
so
you know um we probably should get rid
of half the history textbooks that are
out there
and you know i'll tell you when it comes
to statues
i love the statue that we have for our
civil war people here in milwaukee
because it shows and i've posted this in
in various places it shows
three uh union soldiers trampling over
the
bodies of rebels that's our tradition
here in wisconsin by the way
killing rebels killing confederates
killing racists killing
seditionists and so if that's what you
mean by statues i'm all for that i think
we need more of those
you know i think we should show um
statues of of war criminals being hung
that would be
awesome you know things celebrating a
[ __ ] history that's been whitewashed
so that you know
people can feel good about the waving a
rebel flag
not into that you know so
you're not going to find me a receptive
person to this
statue's argument um
all right let's see another view
limited hangout controlling thoughts if
you think this is controlling your
thoughts
man you're you're badly off
uh all right barklord my family are
conservative libertarians who talk tough
and will not negotiate with democratic
process
complete proprietary and authoritarian
uh sorry to hear that
you know um we got to figure out what
we're going to do
with those those people ross whitlock i
hate both parties they're all terrible
i hate parties too um i i
hate the fact that pretty much anybody
who makes it into politics
uses it to you know make themselves
richer
and put their kids in better schools and
they become part of a political class
a process by the way which rousseau
talks about in the
discourse on the origins of inequality
you know once you've got political power
the money and the prestige will follow
that said um should we say they're all
terrible
no that's that's a silly point of view
and what we should do is we should say
how terrible they are
some are more terrible than others and
we've got to work with the options that
we have that
is one of the key things that again
aristotle are rent
habermas you know all sorts of other
people
politics is about doing what you
actually
can within the framework that you can to
try to achieve
some things that are good and get other
people who don't agree with you to go
along with it
so simply throwing our hands up in the
air and saying oh it's all terrible
um that's not going to get anything done
you know
and we can we can certainly
call here's one thing that i will say
that's good about what you're saying
we should be willing to call out um
both sides this is the legitimate both
scientism
when they are legitimately doing the
wrong thing you know so like
for example democrats who are uh
you know in charge of a city and in the
pocket of police unions
we ought to go after them right that's
that's a good idea
uh when there's corruption taking place
whoever's engaging in corruption ought
to be called out on it
but um this this like it's all bad that
that just doesn't really work for
anything
um
let's see what we got here wow another
view's got some
weird stuff full loss and fee junk fake
philosophers that don't test their
teachings
what is reality that's that's some nice
word salad there
um but this probably isn't the place for
you i'm guessing right
if you get to the point where you're
like writing weird crap uh
because who knows you're you need to say
something
you're sort of like making yourself the
person in the corner who has nothing to
contribute to the conversation
uh andrew do you think more logical
people are conservative and emotive
people learn
lean more left no as a matter of fact i
think that it is
very well distributed across the board i
think if you look at the current right
most of the people that i see on the
right are very driven by emotional
needs and desires some of the great
motifs like that you know think about
the
the incredible passion that people show
about their guns
is that based on anything that's
rational and logical
no and you can go through their
decision-making process i can look at
some of the members of my family who've
blown so much money on guns and blown so
much of their time
arguing with other people about the
second amendment um
that is driven by emotion that is that
is not driven by
you know facts logic any of the things
that they like to appeal to
so so no um
all right let's see what else we've got
here
uh moon child here's so somebody new
what do you think of some democrats
saying
unity means that we can disagree but
violence should not be our way of
settling disputes since we're all
americans
that's what you mean by unity i'm cool
with that you know
and i think that should actually be a
baseline once you cross the line
into violent insurrection you should get
locked up
and have whatever weapons you have
confiscated
and whatever funds have been you know
used to promote you
that should should be confiscated as
well
turn to the public good we could create
all sorts of
cool accounts for that sort of thing um
there are some certain lines that you
can't
you shouldn't be able to cross that were
crossed and and they were crossed by the
way again
think about the the invasion of the
state houses by heavily armed people
who call themselves protesters the court
from where i sit the minute you go to a
protest
and you've got any sort of you know long
rifle
or you're in military gear you're not a
protester you're a terrorist because
you're trying to inspire terror
in other people you know and you're
trying to shut other people
down and if you're doing that in the
state house to try to
you know change you know
policy or something like that you are in
effect using the threat of force
violent force against uh the common good
and those who are supposed to be in
charge so i i'm cool with that
definition
uh goddard damarung twilight of the god
says
is it unreasonable to adopt a normative
theory if you're undecided on the
anti-realism versus realism
debates and meta ethics um no
as a matter of fact everyone has a
normative theory
even the meta ethics people have
normative theories if you're an
emotivist you have
you also have a normative theory i don't
believe in
in the distinction between meta ethics
and normative ethics i think it breaks
down very quickly in practice
and i think everybody actually operates
perhaps inconsistently
with some sort of identifiable moral
theory so
it's not it's not only not unreasonable
to adopt a normative theory
it's also inevitable to do so all right
um
let's see here oop just skipped a little
bit
um a lot of back and forth
about market ideology which we've talked
about a good bit
already um
xenovaleo what do you think about
twitter banning the new brett weinstein
party idea i don't know the new brett
weinstein party idea
so i really can't say anything about it
i will say about twitter banning
um people have been banned on twitter
for a long time
i don't have a problem with people
getting banned on on twitter
violate the the rules um they should ban
you
as a matter of fact trump should have
been kicked off of twitter a long long
time ago but they bent over backwards
for him
uh and his supporters and kind of hoard
themselves out in the process
um i think you know if we have rules we
should apply them
and i think that you know uh if you want
to [ __ ] and whine about being canceled
or being d
platform go somewhere else if you're on
if you're on
tv complaining about your twitter
account being closed you haven't been
censored
uh as a matter of fact you're spouting
stuff about it right then
right so so i i don't know enough about
that particular
thing to to say but i can say that most
of what people say about cancer culture
or you know the dangers of big tech
censoring people is really just
self-serving [ __ ]
they didn't complain about it when it
was people that they disagreed with
getting banned you know sometimes they
actually celebrated that
um so you know
there's there's not much more to say
about that we could probably
uh do do a show about that though um
all right more back and forth that's a
little bit hard to decipher
um
hit j hitchcock says i live in texas for
some people here guns are at the level
of a fetish
they are in in a lot of wisconsin too
and you know um
that's that's that's a good way to put
it there you know going back to like the
emotional
versus rational thing fetishes are not
rationally thought out it's because
somebody's got
deep set anxiety fears
resentments anger that they fixate or
desires
that they fixate on certain things that
they
have to have and those those must be
protected
and it can be part of a person's
identity
you know um
[Music]
i'll say this if having a gun and i say
this is as you know
somebody who who grew up in a
neighborhood full of guns
where you know we actually had a uh
juvenile prison just across the highway
from us every once in a while
they would you know prisoner would break
out and and we would
we'd see people walking around the
street armed you know
with shotguns and pistols and rifles and
i come from a family that that hunts
and and some of them collect guns you
know
the need to have a gun as part of your
identity
is really sad and pathetic
one should be able to build an identity
without that and you could say the same
thing with like
you know martial arts guys back in the
80s you know
if you had to have a pair of nut chucks
right now it's other stuff right
it's just kind of uh it's like a sign of
being stunted
in many ways unfortunately all right
um
so kench says historical work
woke hordes canceling people not at all
driven by emotions great point sadler
that's a dumb comment who said that that
that's not driven
by emotion you read so much stuff in
you it's like you're primed to find
fault right
um but there aren't historical war woke
hordes canceling people most of that is
is a [ __ ] fake narrative that serves
other people's emotions
so all right um
ian france philosopher charles taylor
wrote a good book 30 years ago called
the malaise of modernity
he points towards the instrumental
reason of the state deciding everything
in terms of efficiency
yeah i mean this is a long-standing
thing max weber wrote about this
aleister mcintyre talks about that
in a number of different places it's
it's not like a radically
new point um you know i don't know that
those analyses
are really that helpful for what's going
on in the present
in terms of like our electoral politics
but they could be
interesting to talk about our larger
politics and
they can also be transferred from the
sort of
political sphere into the the economic
sphere as well
all right um
oh in france some follows up with i
believe much of the unrest is sideways
explosion of feeling people
have from being squashed and losing
their voice in the body politic
yeah i mean there's some of that um
certainly the black lives matter
stuff that's legitimately legitimately a
center of it and then seeing the police
responses
to black lives matter as just doing more
of the same police stuff
which they don't get you know uh they
don't get held accountable
for i would say that fits into that i'm
i'm
again you know coming from the the
midwest
and and having lived all over the place
and having people
in my my family who you know work in the
trades and coming from kind of a
blue-collar background
the narrative of like the the typical
trump voter
that you meet in the diner as having you
know
being upset about their their economic
dislocations and not being taken
seriously
i think that that's at best half true i
think that a lot of the people
who supported the trump administration
actually are making good money
uh we've seen that in a lot of cases
um i would say that there's quite a few
people who have been you know sort of
like squashed and economically
dislocated and then they reach out for
um they reach out for racist or sexist
or whatever
explanations because they were racist or
sexist to begin with
they were just doing good for a while
and then
you know things went went badly
all right
cory asks any thoughts on respecting
local resolutions
instead of allowing a senate side
to happen to individuals on social
security
uh not not sure what this
set aside means
oh maybe older people dying off right
thoughts on respecting local resolutions
i don't know how that connects with
local security with social security
social security is a federal program
so although you know states like
illinois
have their own retirement system that's
outside of social security
but unfortunately the state often raids
that fund
which is a big problem right um so i
don't know how to answer that
all right uh paul says the keystone xl
project offered opportunity for america
to come together
union jobs strong environmental controls
while supporting energy industry
awesome talking points i'd i'd love to
see the the you know
site that you you took those from but
unfortunately
uh you left out a lot of the important
stuff as well
that makes it controversial so
all you're doing there is giving some
talking points
um all right let's see who else we've
got
and i'm i i do have to end this a little
bit
uh earlier than i usually do because
we've got some
we got the packers game coming up and
i've got some grading i have to do
um all right
joshua asks what do you think nietzsche
would say about our political
environment
well he'd say that it's uh you know
a sign of like how how screwed up things
are in modernity and he wouldn't like
the
democrats and he wouldn't like the
republicans either and he wouldn't like
their bases
um i think he'd kind of throw his hands
up and he'd say this is a time to
cultivate solitude
um all right um
a lot of back and forth stuff
elianne isn't the gun a fetish of
freedom
well there's a lot of different ways of
understanding freedom
uh it wouldn't be a fetish of freedom it
could be a symbol of freedom but it's a
pretty sad
symbol of freedom given all the other
possibilities that are out there
and given the fact that you know guns
are for killing
guns are for shooting that's that's
their purpose that or intimidating
people
so um you and you say well that's for
self-defense yeah self-defense by
intimidating and shooting right
i mean you know what i have for
self-defense um i don't i don't i don't
you know need a gun but if i go into a
rough place i carry a spring-loaded
baton
you know because uh that sound
is way more satisfying than the click
click that people are always doing in
every show about you know
cocking a gun or something like that um
you know guns are guns are well we gotta
say a whole bunch of stuff i'm not gonna
keep going on and on about this
um ken says the people excuse people
being banned say
go somewhere else then they get service
providers to take down the independent
sites people go to
utter hypocrisy yeah i mean
that's probably happened uh in some
cases i've i've never actually seen a
case where somebody is totally
unable to find a platform to be on but
if you know if that you think that
happens
it'd be cool for you to write like a
long form essay about
the case in which that that happened um
hitchcock says i'm not anti-gun i'm
simply for reasonable regulations and
safety measures like the nra
used to stand for yeah before the nra
turned into a bunch of nutters
um yeah i mean we have a lot of
i i'm actually with you on that we do
have a lot of gun laws
and if they were strictly enforced and
followed
that would curb an awful lot
unfortunately they're often not right
and there's a lot of selective
enforcement
so that's that's a bit of an issue um
sean says if there was genuine election
fraud i know there was not but suppose
there was
was that why that was widespread would
that the capital storming be justified
so if there was widespread election
fraud that was that actually took place
and could be demonstrated then you could
go through the courts
so no the cap storming the capital would
definitely not be justified
um and there was some election fraud
there's always going to be
some election fraud the question is how
much of it
um so it wasn't enough to actually make
a difference
except in crazy whacked out conspiracy
theories right
all right uh
let's see here
julian thoughts about the debate about
whether we should call the capitol
building protesters terrorists like if
they are labeled terrorist
blm protesters or by also extension
terrorists
if blm protesters were actually uh
bringing weapons
and and which for the most part they
didn't certainly not hear much in
milwaukee
you know one of the most segregated
large cities in the united states where
we had
blm protests go past our place routinely
and where i watched quite a few of the
parades
you know who was armed boogaloo boys
cops so
you got to think this through before you
you try to make these equivalencies
and yeah should the capital building
protesters be labeled terrorists
every single one of them who used
violence or threatened violence was a
terrorist
they wanted to inflict terror some of
them wanted to kill people
um they were doing so motivated by you
know
extremist views the notion that you
should
invade the capital to disrupt elections
that's an extremist view
so yeah there's no problem calling them
terrorists
um all right let's see who else we got
here
i haven't taken anything from so far
um
nausea asks an interesting question here
do you think we should be giving a
political platform to people who are
overtly false such as the q anons the
trumpets or the people who raided the
capitol building
um we can frame this in a lot of
different ways so what does it mean to
give a political platform can they
participate in politics
yes if they engage in
crime uh that you know is directed
against the political process maybe they
should lose some of their their rights
you know um should they be
accorded a place in the media
responsible media stuff would actually
say
some of these people um are clearly
too far out there we shouldn't be
covering them let alone
giving them a platform they've already
got their own
preferred platforms to to be on some of
which like fox news aren't extremist
enough for them
at this point so they you know they go
after fox
um and then there should be what
uh mill and bentham call the social
sanction
you know if somebody is i i have no
problem with
saying you know to somebody who's like a
q a non-believer
well you're full of [ __ ] and i'm not
going to listen to anything that you
have to say until you like
you know repudiate that crazy crap and
i'm i'm perfectly fine with other people
doing that you know
i i think it's it's actually doing a
social service
to call people on [ __ ] like that um
so you know that that this sort of a
that was at one time sort of a
mainstream view
right um
joshua asks do you think the death of
god nature concept has
had happened or will happen in america i
think according to ninja it happened a
long time ago
right so there's actually a really great
book out there by samuel harrington that
was written in the 1980s called the
politics at god's funeral he was a
marxist
who took nietzsche seriously this death
of god
meaning you know about the framework
within society and like the devaluation
not just of theology but philosophy
science
those sorts of things and he said well
who who actually benefits from this
you know how how does this actually work
out so
all right um kant
jensen says comments are limited to a
few characters i think a philosopher
should go
show good faith try to understand the
point is trying to make before calling
it a dumb comment
old fan disappointed that's a dumb
comment
uh but it's cool that you want to tell
me exactly how i should do things on my
channel
and it's too bad you're disappointed you
know this is what it is
and there are some views that are really
dumb
there are some questions that people ask
in the classroom that are dumb
and you know you you can
do a video or do a podcast or write a
thing about what you think a philosopher
ought to be and
see if you can get other people to buy
into it all right let's see
let's draw this to a close and see what
else we've got that we can kind of
go out on um
ian says about the death of god parable
was written by nature in the context
that it's already occurred but the news
has yet to reach us
yes but that was news over 100 years ago
so you know presumably it would have
reached us by now
right um
let's see here
hitchcock says it was the same here in
texas blm
protesters weren't armed counter
protesters were yeah i mean this is the
reality of things
we really need to to address that if the
if the
blm protesters were regularly armed you
can bet that there would have been like
national guard shooting them you know uh
which they didn't do with with white
supremacists so
all right um
a lot of back and forth let's see if
we've got a good thing to go
out on um
some book recommendations in here as
well
uh okay so here's a here's a good good
sort of very very broad question
by joseph march why does
authoritarianism seem appealing to many
people
that's kind of a constant i think across
cultures across
times there's always been this
undercurrent
going on and you know
authoritarianism of various sorts
can be appealing for for people who
you know like rousseau has pointed out
they're willing to accept somebody
having power over them
so long as they can kick somebody else
so they can have power over somebody
else
i think that's a big part of it you know
what we what we often call the politics
and culture of resentment
by the way i would recommend reading
nietzsche and reading mock shaler
on on rosantomont so genealogy of morals
beyond good and evil for nietzsche great
good places to go to
and mock schaeler's book resonte month
and and you'll you'll see a lot of stuff
in there that like kind of shows you
where some of the authoritarian impulses
come from i think a lot of people
like authoritarianism because they're
driven by fear
and they you know they they think that
um other people are violating the rules
the norms we gotta
we gotta put all this in in order and
their order always ends up being
something
to go back to augustine it always winds
up being something kind of unhealthy
kind of distorted it's order in a sense
but it's not really
order it winds up being a kind of
culvert disorder um you know
bad laws creep in which augustine says
aren't really laws at all
all sorts of hierarchies that that you
know
are what augustine calls the the human
law
or the the temporal law which is often
quite damaged and and
doesn't map on to what he calls the
eternal law
um there's other things as well you know
um
sometimes people are so traumatized that
they
gravitate towards whoever can make them
feel like they're
somehow whole you know they identify
with the political
figure or the cultural figure and
they'll do whatever that that person has
to say
but authoritarianism by itself is a
broad category
is almost never rooted in
something good but it draws upon things
that are
positively good like again think about
augustine order is a good
right we do have to have order within
society do we have to have it in this
particular
mode where order means clamping down as
much as possible on
on people and and um ruling out a lot of
you know
genuine uh developments and enjoyments
of goods including the development of
human persons
no but that's what some people are are
cool with
so long as we can have um
you know so long as we can have that
that
feeling of order right so
actually that's a good thing to close on
you know augustine says that
evil is always an absence or corruption
or perversion of the good
and that is really the case the good
things that we have
this is why politics is always messy you
know the good things that we have
none of them are absolutely purely
unequivocally good
to use the example of a gun a gun could
be good when it's being used to hunt
food for your family
or to protect you from marauders right
or
i suppose you could use it for other
purposes but it's so easy for it to be
turned to evil
and there's so many things that that can
go wrong with it so
i'm going to close on that uh thanks for
all the questions
uh and and comments even the ones that
that were
kind of off base or carping at each
other
this is a lot of arguments back and
forth in here
we'll do this uh like every other month
you know
we uh next month i'm not sure what the
topic will be but we'll find something
and you know you can find this on the
reason i owe calendar
and in my my facebook
events uh you can also find it
uh talked about in my monthly update
videos which i know some of you watch
so all right gonna end it here